[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben heute zeige ich euch
das beste und leckersten rezepte café
kneipe oder auch im türkischen künstler
ist eine süßspeise die aus südschweden
besteht und dazwischen ist eine leckere
käse und das ganze ist getränke mit
zucker sirup
es gibt mehrere möglichkeiten wie man
nessie zubereiten kann und ich zeige
euch heute im video die palästinensische
organische variante zuallererst wird nun
der zucker sirup er gestellt damit er
auskühlen kann und dafür benötigen wir
400 gramm zucker 400 milliliter wasser
und ein paar spritzer zitronensaft dafür
kochen wir zucker und wasser in einem
topf auf und lassen uns fünf minuten
lang köcheln
[Musik]
nach den fünf minuten legte sirup etwas
ein und dann gehen wir ein paar spritzer
zitronensaft hinzu den sirup lassen
jetzt vollständig auskühlen
jetzt geht es weiter mit der
eigentlichen zubereitung wir benötigen
800.000 kdf das sind in der tiefsee
findet in jedem typischen supermarkt
außerdem 400 gramm geschmolzene butter 1
teelöffel rote lebensmittelfarbe sie
bekommt ihr leider nicht in deutschland
aber wenn die möglichkeit habt dass ihr
euch jemand aus jordanien mitbringt dann
macht es auf jeden fall es geht aber
auch ohne dann brauchen wir noch etwas
weiche butter zum bestreichen der form
und 800 gramm weichkäse
dieser ist extra für sie gedacht ich
zeige euch in meinen die kamera
der ist wirklich super einzige was ihr
beachten müsst das zeige ich euch gleich
dass wir den gründlich waschen und
diesen speziellen kleber den findet ihr
übrigens auch neben typisch arabischen
supermarkt zuallererst sich der kader
mit dem messer in dünne stücke
geschnitten
die type fäden werden dann in eine
ausreichend große schiffe gegeben und
dann noch mal mit den händen fein verruf
dann kommt die geschmolzene butter hinzu
und wird mit den händen sehr gut
vermengt hierbei solltet ihr darauf
achten dass kein teigfladen mehr trocken
bleibt
an dieser stelle kommt noch die rot
orangen lebensmittelfarbe mit hinzu dies
extrem stark segmentiert und ex-profi
gedacht nur leider bekommt man sie in
deutschland nicht sondern nur in
arabischen ländern
also falls sie die möglichkeit dazu habt
nehmt ihr euch auf jeden fall mit der
käse ist für extra stück nervige dachte
sap denn der wald und deshalb muss man
es mehrere male abspülen und am besten
dass wir das sogar die ganze nacht im
wasser stehen und schneidet das auf
jeden fall in das kleine stücke weh
getan habe nachdem ihr das wasser
abzukochen habt könnt ihr den käse auch
so schon verwenden
ich zeige euch aber eine viel bessere
variante sie einfach viel leckerer ist
hierfür benötigen wir zusätzlich noch
300 gramm banner und 40 gramm
speisestärke und die speisestärke
vermisse ich es mit der sahne und weise
wie klümpchen frei
[Musik]
das gebe ich dann in meinen kopf und
lasse das unter rühren einmal aufkochen
und einblicken
[Musik]
sobald das einmal ein gedicht halte ich
den herd auf niedrige stufe gibt den
kirche hinzu und lasse den auch darin
schmelzen dann ist die füllung auch
schon fertig lacht sie nun nicht zu
lange aus kühlen damit es sich zu hart
wird
jetzt nehme ich mir mein tiefes wackelig
unterstreiche das mit meiner portal für
den boden gebe ich jetzt die hälfte
meiner teig fäden auf das blech
nachdem ich alles gleichmäßig verteilt
habe nehme ich mir ein glas zur hand und
drückt das ganze flach an darüber geben
wir dann die befüllung und ich gebe euch
einen tipp macht es auf jeden fall
esslöffel weise
dann könnt ihr das viel besser
verstreichen ohne den boden kaputt zu
machen
[Musik]
sobald wir die füllung dann gleichmäßig
verteilt habt kommt die zweite hälfte
der teig reden darüber
die obere deckschicht habe ich jetzt
auch gleichmäßig verteilt und entgegen
viele rezepte werde ich das jetzt nicht
mit einem glas flaschen drücken sondern
nur mit den händen ganz leicht berühren
das bewegt nämlich dass er kniff sie am
ende noch knuspriger ist jetzt gebe ich
das blech website ober und unterhitze
bis 25 minuten in den backofen ganz heiß
aus dem ofen wird das könnte jetzt noch
mit dem zucker sirup über posten und der
seite galt bis lang sein und hier habe
ich noch einen kleinen tipp muss nicht
immer komplett mit zuckersirup getränk
sein denn ich finde man kann auch immer
etwas daneben reichen also wenn ihr
euren gästen ein stück abgibt dann gibt
dazu noch etwas zucker sirup und wir
können selbst bestimmen
und unser carey ist jetzt auch schon
fertig und am besten serviert ihr dass
schönheit und werk näher für auf meine
art und weise noch nicht probiert hatte
sollte das ganz schnell nachholen die
welt ist nicht bereit ist mit
unglaublich lecker falls euch das video
gefallen hat dann freue ich mich sehr
über ihr feedback und über euer abo bis
zum nächsten mal auf die tiefs kitchen
[Musik]